uh so Pharrell co-produced yeah that's
pretty [ __ ] cool legendary shout out
to Pharrell you know he's one of the
goats he's like on the uh the Mount
Rushmore I'd say hell yeah you know
legendary yeah what uh what's your
relationship like with Pharrell because
um I met him at cuevos
album release party 2018. remember when
Cleveland dropped his album
um I met him at that release party
and then he he said that he was a big
fan and stuff we should link up and then
we kept in touch I started going to
Studio with him working on a lot of
stuff and then this record came about
years later right so it was awesome so
like we definitely wanted to release
something together you know what I'm
saying and then this was perfect so when
you like get the beat originally from
Pharrell
who's one of the greats what is the
sauce you add to it I like
put some of my drums with his drums and
made it crazier and then like did some
Melody stuff produced out the record put
everybody on the record and like yeah
super big and like we both like did
notes for like mixing and mastering he
helped me like with some notes like take
it to the Finish Line like things and
like how to tweak like sequencing the
song and stuff yeah and I think it's
gonna be a huge record for you bro I
appreciate it because as soon as I heard
it I was like oh this [ __ ] I told my boy
Brandon uh from your label I was like yo
this is a this would be easy you know
what I mean yeah I shot a big budget
video in Miami big budget video what is
a big budget video in 2022 I'm just
curious because I think back in the day
they were like really big budget videos
um big budget video for me
is like
3K
God bless like over like 500 000 half a
million that's that's fair you know
that's a big budget yeah for sure yeah
because I feel like back in the day like
when Buster Rhymes and Missy and big
those were like they were like [ __ ]
millions of dollars like think about the
Mo Money Mo Problems video yeah this
[ __ ] had to shut down the ocean
and they had speed boats and [ __ ] oh
yeah that [ __ ] was crazy yeah videos
those times were incredible so what is
the J Balvin call like
so I was in I was in LA at the time it
was like during coven I was working with
Balvin so you were already locked in
with him yeah so I was working with him
already this [ __ ] fly won't go away
shut up shut up the Flies yeah but um I
was already working with him and stuff
so like when I had the record like when
I got the record and stuff I was like yo
this is gonna be perfect to get Balvin
on right so I took it right to him he
loved it he's like yo this is super fire
can't wait to do it he sent me like a
verse back in like a week that's a
pretty nice turnaround for arguably the
biggest artist in the [ __ ] and then
we were kind of we were kind of sitting
on the record for a bit I thought cuevo
might was gonna use it you know and then
he ended up not using this on top of the
year I was like Hey man can I get this
for my shirt yeah yeah